this is a pivotal week for our company
when you open yourself up to criticism
it's natural to get some nerves but
we're very prepared and we hope to put
on a killer show for everybody Roger
gentlemen began as a blog and it allowed
me to develop my own point of view on
menswear eventually we took that leap
develop their own clothing line and
you'll be able to see that the show on
someone you're about to spend a week
with me at you're crashing
on Monday the models came through our
creative studio we fit them in our
clothes we tried on a couple of
different looks got them where we felt
comfortable you want to really be able
to focus on detail and execution the day
of and eliminate any fluff that could be
in the way all right that's what we mean
by grungy gentleman very classy but with
little edge up top on Tuesday I'll do a
lot of the locks Jadakiss Styles P sheek
louch they all came and we put our
clothes on the guys and made sure that
they were super confident and ready to
crush it it's Wednesday we're on our way
to dwell Santana's office Dipset we're
gonna fit him in some clothes for our
runway show JS my budget is about what
we went over music direction we want to
discontinue do music and you want to
just do faster so it's always a way to
this branch out a little bigger and
better things I mean he was the ones
first put the Louboutin dings over our
head and I'm saying next thing you know
we go on the store the prices up it's
gonna be powerful on Thursday
we fit my brother Skyler for our event
with express that was the next day
friday was an awesome awesome night
Steph Curry Ludacris Express here we
come poor seeing everybody interact with
the product that you helped create is
amazing all the way
we went to time square where we had a
triple billboard the Billboard generally
cost around twenty thousand dollars an
hour expressed on that billboard and
through our partnership we were able to
have that billboard for two days fredo
on sunday is game day
what is this guy's um if you can we just
kind of group you guys together for a
minute so we can get a head count I need
ice bucket for the beer I like to
confuse the audience so we're starting
it off with unforgettable 15 minutes to
Showtime now tell them to lift your hair
oh that's my favorite come here real
quick do this the reason why we work
with athletes musicians actors is
because it expands our reach it allows
us to gain exposure into industries that
we necessarily aren't cemented in yet
appreciate you guys
being able to work with these gentlemen
they're such heavy influence in society
that when they post whether your social
media or people see them interacting
with the product in real life whether it
be through photographs and circulate on
the internet or then on television it's
amazing the response from it leads to
direct sales and as a young business
that's what you want I was a little
hesitant to go on stage during the
finale because it's not about me it's
about the brand I actually want to give
a high five to jewels which we did not
plan so it was a moment I'll never
forget at the end of the day fashion
does show a lot of glitz and glamour
this is a business if you don't have
sales you're not going to be in business
for long so we have to use our fashion
show as a vehicle to create revenue for
our company talent whether I work with a
new customer and editor buyer I treat
everybody the same I try to treat
everybody like a friend and that's what
we think it runs a gentleman is a little
bit of a family and kind of we call it
the home team so you try to put everyone
in the home
the show is over five months of hard
work are over what can I say we feel
blessed we're humbled and we're also
looking forward to the future it's a
wrap